all right good evening everyone
it's 5:30 and we will get started now
the first item on the agenda apologies
for absence we have received apologies
from cats love hot thank you
declaration of interests by councillors
do we have any nope
right the next item BCA 1921 to confirm
the minutes of the meeting held on the
10th of October 2019 so you've all got a
copy of the minutes and we'll go through
them at page 1 page 2 page 3 page 4 and
page by any questions on accuracy or
content okay
yeah okay I was just going through the
paper one just because I have to sign
the paper one absolutely but I have the
electronic one here in front of me okay
[Applause]
all those in favor of the minutes though
thank you moving on to the next item
which is paper BCA 1922 the Suffolk
coast oh gosh sorry I've missed that one
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme and questions by councillors and
matters are referred by the overview
scrutiny or joint board and standards
committees no receive check the next
item on the list forthcoming decisions
to this you've all received copies of
that and obviously there are a number of
things on that that are going to change
as a result of the the election so the
an up-to-date forthcoming decisions list
will be issued shortly to reschedule
quite a number of things any other
comments on on that from anyone okay the
next item then is BCA 1922 the Safa
Coast director ocean of disturbance and
avoidance mitigation strategy and I'd
like to ask the cabinet member for
planning to introduce this paper please
Thank You chairman um yeah there are a
lot of things I can say about this or I
could keep it quite short so I'll start
off shortish and see how much more you
want me to add it's a huge document but
it won't be a surprise to you because of
course it was mentioned in
joint logo plan consultation policy SPO
nine and indeed the zone of influence
map was was included in our local plan
document Rams is the recreational
avoidance and mitigation strategy and
this is for the Suffolk coast and you'll
see in the document that is effects
Baber mid Suffolk East Suffolk and tips
which there are a couple of things that
I think I perhaps ought to say and that
is that it's a legal requirement that
habitat regulations assessments are
undertaken for development proposals
within a zone 13 kilometers away from
the protected habitat and for Baber this
is the area of the store and Orwell
estuary in the report you will see that
the zone is defined we're in zone a
there's a zone a and a zone B that's on
page sixty eight of the committee papers
54 of the report and you'll see there
the two colored zones the contributions
for Zone A which is the area that
affects Baber will be a hundred and
twenty-one pounds eighty nine paper
dwelling and you'll also see a little
bit later on in the in the report that
contributions across both zones and for
all or all authorities come to a total
of three million seven hundred seventy
seven hundred and fifty seven pounds
that's the projected costs of the
fifteen years for a strategy if you look
at pages 119 to 124 which is 105 to 110
of the strategy report that details what
the projected costs are likely to be
spent on you will see that most of
resources are required for various
staffing issues you'll see in there that
there's the delivery officer there are
wardens and then there are various
projects that are mentioned which would
be required it's all about controlling
and protecting sensitive areas this has
already been to mid Suffolk and I have
to say that the area of mid suffer
perfected is not quite as large as the
area of Baber affected you'll see in the
map that the affected area for babe of
the zone of influence actually goes just
to the west of Hadley so it's quite a
large area it went to mid Suffolk
cabinets who spent quite a long time
discussing it with quite a few questions
and some of that questioning was around
the fact that the proposed board is
officer only it's two officers from the
planning team of each authority and as a
result of their debate they suggested
revision and that's what I'm going to
recommend to you they have suggested
that after Assistant Director for
sustainable communities in the
recommendation so if you have a look at
your recommendation on page 11 you'll
see it says at 3.2 that delegated
authority is granted to the assistant
director for sustainable communities to
determine and they have suggested that
after communities you insert the words
in consultation with the cabinet member
for planning and the cabinet member for
environment so with the current post
holders that have been my my cell phone
capsule now V Z and then carry on after
that with to determine the method of
implementation via an implementation
board so that is the recommendation on
page 11 3.1 that the Suffolk coast rams
is approved for adoption and to the
delegated authority with the insertion
of the cabinet member for planning and
the cabinet member for environment thank
you Thank You councillor Aarthi and
members of the cabinet are there any
questions on this report at the moment
Custer Davis it's more of a comment
really but obviously we've been taken in
Rams payments for some time now I'm not
just curious as to how much we've
already raised in payments from
developers because I know we've already
had some some perhaps I can find out for
that but overall I think this is an
excellent strategy that we should adopt
because it's really important that we
protect our air is a store not oh well
estuaries obviously put particular
interests of myself and know the a o and
B is being expanded but it's important
that we do have this the Rams are and
I'm delighted that the Rams area the
zone has actually increased so it's not
just homes within the immediate vicinity
because clearly a lot of people come to
enjoy our particular areas but it's
important as well to find that balance
between for example walkers and dog
walkers and protects in the bird life
for example which of which we have lots
of on the store Norwell areas so I'm
fully in favor of this but I'm just
curious as to how much we've already
raised to say that Rob is here to help
with all of the questions that I can't
answer and that's one of them
unfortunately I can't I questioned out
it's night I'll find out for you and
advise the old cabinet horny actually
following on from that I've got a
question out that 3.7 million is the
amount that we we believe we need to
raise in order to prevent the adverse
effects on on the the European sites so
presumably with it that's within zone
the zones that they're affected
immediately by Weber and mid Suffolk or
by Weber alone or no that's for the
whole coast so if you look at page one
one nine of the report the tables there
go through all of the projected costs as
I said most of it is is staffing for
we've got a delivery officer one two
three full-time wardens and then you can
see staff time some external support for
the wardens if you go through they
conceived of various project costs and
yes it's for the whole top of coast and
and therefore there's two tariffs have
been set in order to generate that that
amount of money from the projected new
housing that according for the new local
plan numbers presumably yes and the
other question is so that money there's
been that that's been raised before the
the mitigation measures but there's also
talk in section nine point two four of
the report on words about the use of
section 106 and sill monies as well sill
for the infrastructure for some interest
related work and section 106 a non
infrastructure related work so in
addition to that three point seven
million we can use other sources of
planning as well is that okay
I haven't even got to the bit you've
referred to yet but I'm sure you arise
I'll get there in a second
chairman I'm going to refer to an to rob
Hobbs on that one I think the answer is
yes it's the paragraphs and I point to
four onwards which are on page 99 of the
report which is page 113 of a report
pack so in answer to the question what
what I've set up in the covering report
is um we can actually use some hew
section 106 agreements on sites of tens
Wellings or more as part of the general
section 106 or what we've actually
looking at now is potentially using them
what's known as session one-on-one where
we effectively collect the money upfront
and then hold on to it until development
has either commenced or if planning
permission is actually refused and
returning the money accordingly or we
can do a unilateral undertaking for a
single and development I think though
that the question was more can other
funding sources be used with in regard
to some of these projects or not the
question was that we've got the the
tariffs for dwelling to raise the 3.7
million to spend on the mitigation
measures but we're also looking at
sources beyond funding beyond that over
and above that 3.7 million but not for
the schedule of expenses and projects
that are listed on page
one Table six
yes point plate is one one nine two two
four that's that basically is costing
everything based on the contributions
that have been calculated for the growth
in zone a and Zone B adding up all of
those contributions the projected level
of funding and the projected costs are
all set out in that table so that
doesn't anticipate any funds from
elsewhere but if the question was do any
of these projects or could any of these
projects be extended with funds from
elsewhere I think the answer is yes yes
it is thank you does anyone else have
any castle mal BC that we should also
implement sorry we should expand
promotion by including more members
because I think that any project any
report any piece of work that the
council does of this magnitude with only
two officers and no councillors sitting
on the board is not it's not good
practice so I think like mid Suffolk we
should implement that as well so you're
in favor the amended recommendation yeah
okay thank you to be sure about that
that's not to sit on the board
why well I've reported to you what with
Suffolk had done and I'm suggesting that
we should do the same it would be that
the authority is granted to the
Assistant Director for sustainable
communities together with a consultation
with the cabinet member for planning and
the cabinet member for the environment
okay so that's not seeds on the ball
with the seeds on the board I'm gonna I
might have to let you rot for this one
I think we've nominated or we're about
to nominate are we two members of your
team to sit on that board so the toss is
concerned that the corporate manager for
realm public realm and the professional
leader key sighs an infrastructure
council Busby well I've got real
problems with it with this really I
think yeah I sympathize with the cause I
think it's important that we do protect
the areas that were referring to but the
process that we can just almost at the
drop of a hat decide to raise 3.7
million pounds without any seat without
any scrutiny of the figures and without
almost any control of the spending by
members going forward I mean a quarter
of a million pounds facing for little
turns who's decided that two hundred and
fifty two hundred and twenty five
thousand pounds that we've we can raise
this way is best spent on providing
fencing for little turns that's crazy
new interpretation boards a quarter of a
million quid whose cost did that and
have that will let go out for
competitive quotes how are we going to
control this 3.7 million pounds has some
awful lot of money
and if we can do it this simply for this
why can't we do it for
for the bus services or for the roads or
whatever it's just we've just suddenly
like this has just suddenly come forward
4 million pounds will raise it will
spend it like this without any kind of
control just say about that I mean it's
not 4 million pounds from Babybel it's
yes it's 3/4 million collected in
contributions from new dwellings across
the to zone yeah baby overall zone of
influence for protection of the Suffolk
coast okay over a 15 year period so if
you I haven't done the sun's I don't
know if rob has but if you do the sums
the amount that but new dwellings in
Baber will contribute on an annual basis
is obviously a much much smaller figure
Rob do you happen to have that figure
not directly available we were talking
about 121 pounds per dwelling and last
year in favor
there was 579 dwellings completed no
because that was over the whole of Baber
it's only dwellings in the zone yeah
which doesn't include sub pre equipment
about 1% on our council tax for the next
15 years yeah you'd say no but it is if
it's costing us about 40,000 pounds a
year then that's equivalent of 1% on a
council tax for 15 years now I'm not
argue we shouldn't do it necessarily and
I'm not arguing that I think it's a good
way of doing it but it it doesn't seem
to be any kind of control into how we
spend it who's worked out the figures
and who's decided that a quarter million
pound spent on fencing for little turns
is the best way of spending a quarter of
a million quid absolutely so unfortunate
to have the benefit than having
through a couple of presentations about
Rams at the store and all the forum
beforehand and we had an excellent
presentation from servants Solent which
is down near Portsmouth so that
particular area and I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I think they may have
been the first ones that came up with
the idea but obviously if they there
their model has been adapted throughout
in various areas and they're the ones
that have come up with these figures in
terms of for example car park and which
ones are used i don't walk as walkers in
particular areas but the effect for
example these figures come up and this
is being mentioned we're not bearing the
cost of this as taxpayers research
they're coming from the developers so
the payment will come that's the whole
point and that's why it's been worked
out as a mean throughout the country and
because of the house prices in certain
areas that as that's how its adjusted on
that that's my understanding from the
presentations that I've had so which is
why aren't quite favouring this because
it's people that want to live on the
coast that are paying that little bit
extra but you know we'll be a hundred
twenty nine pound or whatever yeah it's
a vote for that privilege to help us
mitigate the damage because if we didn't
draw it from the rest of the developers
or the builders of those we would
probably have to find them anyway
because this has been mentioned in the
report this is a national thing that we
need to mitigate an avoidance strategy
yeah it's it's the European habitats
directive which we've got to implement
and although this strategy is optional
it's it's a more efficient and effective
way of raising the money from the
developers and the developers having to
implement their own strategies each time
for each individual development and so
it's not a question of not not doing
this it's a question of what's the best
mechanism to do this yes I take your
point with we're raising a significant
amount of money on new development for a
specific purpose which is which
one thing and I do take the point about
other things that we might need to raise
money for that that's that's one issue
but that's something we we've got to do
and your other point about how that 3.7
million has been derived and the
assessment of the the individual
projects and the cost of projects well I
assume that those have been drawn up
with expert advice and that term the
little terms do warrant fencing around
their breeding sites and and other
things are are necessary I think while
we can challenge whether that the amount
of money allocated to that is the right
amount with I think we've got to take it
on board that a lot of that has been put
put together by expert advice on the
specific things that are required in
these these these zones that we have
along the East Anglian coast I
appreciate is an efficient way of
raising money I haven't got a problem
and we have to do it I agree we have to
do that as well
and I'm sure the people that are buying
new houses will appreciate having to pay
an extra hundred and twenty quid on top
of three hundred and fifty thousand
they're already paying for for a small
house in Suffolk I would be happier if
this went through scrutiny ons either
now before or very soon to for them to
scrutinize and be comfortable with these
figures it's a lot of money and I'm not
happy of proving a quarter a million
pounds fencing for little terms if
somebody says well that's the really is
good value and this is how we came up
with the figures and it's essential
because we've only got 60 pairs breeding
pairs left in the world and they happen
to be honest of a Coast and if there's
two and a half million of these little
turns why are we building a quarter
million pound fence they've had it's it
looks to me as though they've had a
wishlist
you know if somebody's come sat down and
thought of that any number almost and
put this down and come up with nearly
four million pounds I just want you to
scrutinized by OH&S that's support casa
móvil see I think Arthur Arthi and these
are indicative estimates they're not
actual and they're guidelines you can't
just say I'm not quite sure where
councillor Busby is coming from here
I've had a look at policy SPO nine in
our draft Local Plan it says development
that creates new dwellings within the
identified protected habitat sites
mitigation zone will need to consider
impacts where relevant development will
be required to make appropriate
contributions through section 106
agreements towards management projects
and/or monitoring of visitor pressure
and urban effects on habitat sites and
be compliant with the HR a recreational
disturbance and avoidance mitigate
mitigation strategy okay there's a whole
lot of supporting text to that as well
which I won't read out to you as I say
the zoning signs of influence in in the
document and I'm now looking at the
responses to that particular policy just
to see if you know Dave Busby saying you
know you know should we really be doing
this so other than their sponsors so how
do they do it okay it's the it's the
amounts right okay I'll give you an
example of somebody who's objected and
the objection is from Hopkins homes in
here and they're actually no they're
actually saying because the local plan
didn't have this document with it so
they didn't know the amounts they've
actually said that the policy lacks
clarity it should include further
details and details at the level of
contribution required in other
authorities a figure of three hundred
three hundred pounds per dwelling is
used which helps to provide clarity
okay well we're actually talking about
is it 121
and I know that the others Oh which is
not barbarous is much higher 320 odd but
the point is that if we're going to do
this and we've said that we're going to
do it when we actually come when we
actually come up with it that's not the
time to say should we be doing it that
sort of like I say to every logic
we're committing four million pounds of
not our money of people that are buying
houses money for this purpose all I'm
saying is I want to ensure that they're
getting the best value for that money
because it would be very easy what
happens if they say oh well they're
fencing for the little turns actually
came in at three hundred and twenty five
thousand or who's to say they couldn't
do it for a hundred twenty-five thousand
I just want to get best value for the
money that we're raising I haven't got a
problem with us raising it it's a great
way of doing it but so a lot of money
what kind of control is there on the
spend okay um councillor Davis then
councillor Parker and then I'm going to
ask because we have the chair of
overview and scrutiny in the room I will
then pass it over to to him to have a
few words but councillor Davis first
yeah but first first of all this is
gonna be reviewed in 18 months time so
if we're not charging them enough then
that's where it'll get picked up and
well yeah the part that the charges will
be adapted but as I've said you know
these this is not we're not inventing
the wheel here this has been done
elsewhere so that the fingers are coming
from that and as counsel my vaisyas
pointed out their addictive figures
because this is what is understood
judging for most of all we know how much
it would cost positive
roughly to have all the mitigation and
avoidance what what the unknown factor
at this stage is how many houses will
actually be built up built out in those
particular areas so it could be that we
do need to raise more money but as far
as everything is concerned this won't be
coming from the normal to if you like
the taxpayer research it will be from
these new developments councillor Parker
yeah Thank You Chad I'm coming to large
extinct accounts that Davis has already
said it but I mean I - I'm slightly
confused with respect about what it is
that councilor Busby is is trying to say
here as much as anything else
early on up on a point of order chair
with really what we're being asked to
consider here is the is the mechanism by
which we implement this rather than the
money that's being spent itself so yes
I'm scratching my head as well as my
fundament this chair okay thank you for
that I think we probably all them could
go with that but council McCraw have you
got a few comments on this is the chair
of overview scrutiny thanks Jared I
think I do
from the scrutiny viewpoint and this is
on the basis of scrutiny practice as I
understand it this is I believe a a
statutory requirement it covers the
efforts of four separate authorities
from that point of view it would be
difficult to scrutinize the Bayboro
component separately without reference
to the views of those other councils or
at mid stuff ugh we could do because
obviously we sit in joint committee
however if switch and East Suffolk not
so much the other factor of course is
that some of these figures I mean let's
toast
take for example and I'm just going
through this the little turns it is in
fact 15,000 pounds a year over 15 years
now the headline figure might be 2,000
225 pounds but 15,000 pounds is not that
greater degree of
an amount of money and we are talking
about as I say a statutory requirement
so I'm not sure the way the role of
scrutiny would apply in this because
what would we be scrutinizing where
would be we adding value and in terms of
changing a decision now this is a
cabinet decision and has been gone
through since 2016 is that wrong so it's
been three years in the development
already had there been any concerns
about this in the past I think they
would have been brought up by now this
was never even considered for our work
plan as of on the forthcoming decisions
list I appreciate councillor Busby
disagrees but I'm trying to look at this
fine but I'm saying this was not listed
as a key decision I have to say I've
looks to me from having seen it in
preparation for this meeting that this
seems to me a necessary piece of
legislation a statutory requirement it's
seen as robust and and I'm the only
thing I was going to add prior to this
possibility of overview and scrutiny
examining it was that if you'd is
adopted by this council and I believe it
will be by all four councils I believe
it should be publicized and explained to
the purged eneral public rather better
because we see in planning reports all
the time
Rams assessment it's never quite clearly
explained what Rams necessarily is and I
think that's a good point of
communication that we could be making
with the electorate as a whole and I'll
be quite frank with you with members as
a whole sometimes I think we forget
we've got so many acronyms we can't keep
track of them all that's have Ram's
explained for all of us but I don't see
at the moment any particular argument
for this coming to overview and scrutiny
and by the way our work plan has already
been heavily affected by recent events
and we're going to have to cram six
months work into four months so I'm not
sure that we could deal with it as
quickly as councillor Busby seems to
suggest Thank You councillor crawl and
just for your information cattle buzz be
the little turn breeding colonies on
gravel or shingle coasts and islands at
beginning of the 19th century it was a
common bird of European Shores rivers
and wetlands but in the 20th century
populations of coastal areas decreased
because of habitat loss pollution and
human disturbance the loss of inland
populations has been even more severe
and it has declined to become extinct in
many European countries so 15,000 pounds
a year is probably a reasonable amount
are there any other questions from
members councillor Aarthi yeah what
people were talking I did take the
trouble to go through all of the
responses to this part of the draft plan
and there were I think about 27 that
commented there were eight that fully
supported it there were three that just
sort of made comments of the objections
twelve of the people who objected
actually said that we ought to be doing
more okay there was one that's which was
Hopkins one that I quoted we've said
that they needed some clarity and there
were three that seemed to say and we're
not quite doing it in the right way I'm
not quite sure what other way we could
do this because I mean this is a
nationally recognized strategy so I
don't know if Rob can help with that but
I'm kind of convinced at those
particular responses to the local plan
there isn't really any other way to do
it so I would say that on the local plan
consultation this had more support
probably than most of the other parts of
the plan thank you rob have you got
comment on that
yeah in producing the strategy we've
worked closely also with Natural England
who are they'll see the statutory agency
her and this and we'll feel them
ourselves naturally England and the
other authorities involved that this is
the most effective way of
doing this as has been already alluded
to yeah we've taken evidence from other
strategies as well in terms of how they
cost have been arrived at and the
alternative to doing this is simply
developers doing a single habitat rate
assessment project for each planning
application which is quite rude argument
not as an effective way of doing it
thank you does anyone else have any
questions or comments
okay um castrati has proposed a
recommendation may have a second event
councillor Davis I'm sorry
as amended yes sir just been reminder
the recommendation as amended by
councillor Aarthi in his introduction
counselor Davis thank you all those in
favor
all those against any abstentions okay
Thank You councillor
the next the next items if I can just
move the page we have to exclude the
public from the next item and first of
all we need to consider whether proceed
to the pop on a scheduled highway of the
Local Government Act 1972 the public
should be excluded from the meeting for
the business specified below on the
grounds that if the public were present
during the site temperature slightly
that there would be its disclosure to
them of accept information as indicated
against the item the author of the
report proposed to be considered in part
two of the agenda is satisfied that the
public interest in maintaining the
exemption outweighs the public interest
in disclosing the information so I'm
proposing we go to a confidential
session may have a seconder
a council well VC all those in favor
Experion topic thank you
you
now there isn't a joint cabinet member
briefing on Monday